تنمو على طول لحية إجراء
مكالمة هاتفية دولية مع وجود
جواز سفر ، هذه كلها أسباب يمكن أن
تهبط بك فيما يسميه المسؤولون الأمريكيون
معسكرات الاعتقال في الصين
مفصّلة وكشف مفصل وما يبدو
أنه تقرير مراقبة الحكومة الصينية
على مواطنيها الذي تم تسريبه من شين
جانغ.  المنطقة الواقعة في غرب الصين حيث
أجبرت سياسة الاعتقال الجماعي ما يصل إلى
مليوني مسلم ، معظمهم من
أقلية ويغر العرقية في البلاد ، على
الاحتجاز ، الوثائق عبارة عن
جداول بيانات لأكثر من ثلاثمائة
أسرة تعيش في أحد أحياء
مقاطعة كاراكاش ، وهي تقدم
معلومات شخصية مفصلة للغاية  المعلومات بما في ذلك
أرقام الهوية الوطنية عناوين المنزل
تاريخ الممارسات الدينية للسفر إلى الخارج
وما إذا كانت تمثل تهديدًا أم لا ،
يعتقد المؤلفون أنهم
مسؤولون حكوميون صينيون ، ثم يقررون ما إذا كانوا
سيبقون الأفراد في ما
تسميه الحكومة الصينية مراكز التدريب المهني.
هذه
الكتلة جو  برنامج b التدريبي يستأصل
التطرف العنيف لكن العديد من الناجين
يقولون لشبكة CNN إن الحقيقة هي أن هذه المعسكرات كانت
مزدحمة مثل السجون حيث
تعرض النزلاء للتعذيب بسبب
القمع الصيني والستار الثقيل من
الرقابة التي تؤكد بشكل مستقل أن
أي شيء في شينجيانغ صعب للغاية
على a.  الزيارة الأخيرة
للمنطقة قامت قوات الأمن الصينية
بمضايقة ومنعت سي إن إن أنهار حصيرة من
زيارة معسكرات الاعتقال ، لكن
تحقيق سي إن إن تعقب الفتيات الصغيرات اللائي
يعشن في المنفى الذين تحققوا من
هويات ثمانية على الأقل من
العائلات المذكورة في
التقرير المسرب.  إلى اسطنبول
تركيا هنا قابلت روز نيسا محمد تاتي ،
وهي أم لثلاثة أطفال من شينجيانغ ،
واسمها موجود في وثيقة الوثيقة ،
هذا هو اسمك ،
ظهر اسمها تحت القضية رقم ثلاثة وخمسة
وثمانية والتي كشفت أيضًا أن
أختها الصغرى باتوم تم إرسالها إلى
في مارس 2018 لانتهاكه المزعوم
لسياسة تنظيم الأسرة في الصين  الجليدية
التي لديها الكثير من الأطفال ، شخص ما ،
شكرًا لك كيلي ، كما أن طباشير الأم الحقيقية
هناك يقف في جيب المعلم ،
حسنًا ، أنا معه ، أعطه الرجل الذي
يمكنك الحصول عليه مع السيدة.  تقول روزن عيسى
إن هذه هي المعلومات الأولى التي حصلت
عليها عن عائلتها في شينجانج منذ عام
2016 ، تقول العديد من الفتيات اللاتي نعيش في الخارج إن
الاتصال مع عائلاتهن في
الوطن قد انقطع تمامًا عندما
كثفت الصين حملتها القمعية في شينجيانغ ،
لكن البعض ممن نلعنهم يخاطرون
بحياتهم لفضحهم.  هذه
المعلومات الحساسة هذه هي المرة الأولى
التي تتحدث فيها علنًا عن هذه
المستندات ، نعم هذه هي المرة الأولى التي يكون فيها
تاهو جون أنور ناشطًا
في ويغر يعيش في المنفى في هولندا الصيف الماضي ،
وقد تلقى هذه المجموعة من
الوثائق من مصدر في شينجيانغ
فاز به.  لم يتم التعرف عليهم من أجل سلامتهم
كان عيد ميلادي وحصلت على
مستند المرفق وقد فوجئوا به
للغاية وهو موجود في الوار جنبًا إلى جنب مع مجموعة
من الفتيات الأخريات اللائي نعيش في المنفى
الذين نشارك هذه المعلومات مع
العالم الخارجي هذه الوثيقة  يشبه
صورة مصغرة لما يحدث في جميع أنحاء
نهايات Shin Jang Adrienne هو أكاديمي مقره
في الولايات المتحدة كان يدرس ما هو
مقتنع به
وثائق الحكومة الصينية الداخلية هذا هو
مستقبل الاستبداد ، هذا هو
مستقبل تغيير السكان الذين لا يتفقون
مع النظام الرئيسي من حيث
الأيديولوجية والروحانية والهوية السياسية
أو معايير أخرى يكشف تحليل بيانات سي إن إن
بين 484 شخصًا على الأقل تم إرسال
خمسة منهم إلى المعسكرات.  محتجزون لأنهم
تواصلوا مع أشخاص في الخارج ،
تم احتجاز 25 شخصًا لحملهم جواز سفر
دون زيارة دولة أجنبية ، وتم
تصنيف أكثر من 114 شخصًا على أنهم
تهديد لمجرد وجود عدد كبير جدًا من
الأطفال ، تم إرسال هؤلاء نحن الفتيات إلى
أربعة مخيمات مختلفة تقع جميعها على ما يبدو
داخل نفس المجتمع  باستخدام
وثائق حكومية صينية أخرى مفتوحة المصدر ، تمكنا من العثور على
مواقع المرافق الأربعة
بما في ذلك مركز التدريب رقم 2
الواقع بالقرب من محطة قطار كركاش
، وهذا هو المكان الذي تحدثت فيه روزا ليزا محمد
عن شقيقة تي الكبرى الثانية روزا ناس
وتم إرسالها
وفقًا للحالة  عدد خمسة تسعة سبعة
لكل جريمة الحصول على جواز السفر والعطاء
ولادة الكثير من الأطفال تخشى روزا نيسا
أن تتعرض عائلتها
لمزيد من العقاب لأنها تُعلن عن
سبب قيامك بإظهار وجهك
للعالم الخارجي ، لقد اعتقدت أن
لونًا خفيفًا في لنكولن مع وجود سبعة هالوجين على يديك ،
ثم مطبخ بيكي أشواغاندا
هناك قاتل  live Mulan
كن خفيًا نعم نعم بوسطن في
الأدغال.لادن على قيد الحياة
تواصلت سي إن إن مع وزارة الخارجية الصينية
وحكومة شينجانغ
الإقليمية كتابة بأسئلة مفصلة
لكن المسؤولين الصينيين لم
يردوا في الماضي ،
ونفت بكين بشدة مزاعم
سوء المعاملة والاحتجاز التعسفي.
بالنسبة إلى تاهو جون غير مرغوب فيه ، فإنه يأمل في
أن تجبر مشاركة هذه الوثائق
بكين على تخفيف حملتها القمعية في
شينجيانغ وتؤدي إلى معلومات حول
أحبائه المفقودين ، هذا هو
والدي وهو الآن في السجن. لا
أعرف بالضبط ما هي جريمة الصينيين.
الحكومة دعنا نحرر والدي على
الفور ودعونا نطلق سراح كل
Watson CNN على الفور